a controversial project from the start
worth billions of dollars is now as good
as that not stream 1 and 2 were not
transporting gas to Germany at the time
of the leaks but looking at the extent
of the damage experts wonder if they
will ever be used again
while it's still anyone's guess who is
responsible for what looks like an
attack on the pipelines the leaks reveal
how vulnerable Europe's energy Supply is
especially since Russia's invasion of
Ukraine the annual Valley series we're
in a serious situation in Europe we've
long been aware that the Baltic Sea is
an area of high attentions look at the
rhetoric around Finland and Sweden's
membership of NATO the Baltic Sea is an
area where you have to expect this many
in Europe have accused Russia of
sabotaging their own pipelines and
speculated that more attacks could come
Moscow has rejected his accusations
saying it's the Americans who benefit
most from the price of gas going up
analysts say a high level of expertise
is needed to cause this kind of damage
you need infrastructure for it you need
equipment for it you need money for it
you need expertise for it it can't be
done that easily so there's there's a
couple of organizations only that can
actually do this which also means you
can hedge that means you bring in
probably a lot more intelligence than
military to anticipate anything that
might happen and that might lead to a
much more secure system hundreds of
millions of cubic meters of gas which
were left in the pipelines has been
pouring into the Baltic Sea
the main gas leaking from North stream
into the Baltic Sea is methane this has
a much larger impact on global warming
than the CO2 if the gas is burnt
depending on how much of it is absorbed
by sea water and how much goes up in the
air experts say it could do as much
damage to the climate as the CO2
emissions of a metal large city like
Helsinki for an entire year
just a few days before the leaks were
detected hundreds of Germans held a
rally demanding that the government
start operating North stream too like
many in Europe Germans are struggling to
pay their energy bills after Russia got
supplies in response to sanctions
imposed by the West to make sure that we
have reasonably priced gas again and
that the sanctions are ended that's why
I'm here
Germany has been looking for
alternatives to Russian gas the damaged
North stream pipes have made it even
more clear that the country needs a more
secure supply of energy stepfast and Al
Jazeera in Luckman on the Baltic Sea